this episode of the pain game podcast is
sponsored by surf shock surf shock is a
virtual private network that allows you
to access content anywhere in the world
you can unblock websites that ordinarily
you wouldn't be able to see and it
encrypts your data to give you some
protection out there on the internet
christmas is coming up sometimes you
might just want to watch a christmas
special from another country well now
you can jump on the old netflix if you
want switch it from uk to america or
america to spain and enjoy the ride on
santa sleigh and this couldn't come at
about a time really because surf shock
have got a very festive deal oh yeah
christmas is about giving use my link in
the description below and use the code
geordi to get 83 off and four months
extra for free and if you aren't happy
surf shop offer a 30-day money-back
guarantee so there's no risk so sign up
now use my code and merry christmas but
for now enjoy the podcast
[Music]
at one time i was homeless instead of
going home every night there was no home
to go to
life at home was very difficult i grew
up being abused
i lost my belt i lost respect i
embarrassed my family my vision was
pretty much non-existent i was able to
just about scrape by the medicals
i come out i have supreme confidence and
i'm scared to death
i'm afraid of everything
i didn't care about living i just wanted
to die i got up and i felt the weight of
the world was lifted off my shoulders i
knew i was going to make a comeback
fight this was designed for me to do
what makes us who we are
i'm so far ahead again
my dream my vision for myself is to be
the greatest martial artist to ever live
i have always been a fighter there's
nothing i do better in this life than
fighting
there ain't never been a month like that
to me i was born to do this
nobody can get close i'm the
[Music]
sorry for the delay
my wardrobe department uh caught a
little
problem
and it's good to have a big production
team here you know thank god for them
and they saw that my shirt was wet
and sent me uh back to wardrobe uh to
get fixed up for you guys have they done
your makeup as well teddy no makeup
because that's the one thing i made a
concession on that there's no makeup in
the world that can help on this
particular guy um so
you know we we have a tight budget so we
try to save you know we don't want to
waste money teddy uh my name's brian i'm
a podcaster in the uk who happens to be
a huge fan of you
i
have gone on a bit of a journey learning
about boxing
i've always been a fan but i really
started to get into it um
a lot in terms of the technical sides of
it and i find you help me more than
anyone understand boxing
and your knowledge
from the past
uh you've got so much experience and uh
real
you know
real great stories and you tell them
like nobody else can
so i've really wanted to interview you
for a long time mate so thank you for
the time today well thank you for those
words it means a lot to me no problem i
appreciate that very much and i think
it's great that a man
who started a youtube channel uh later
on in life is having a lot of successes
uh great to see well it's better than
not having success so i i feel very
blessed
and very appreciative to people like you
and the many people out there that have
helped us be successful well honestly uh
this is an honor you know you're you are
boxing to me you are you clearly lived
and breathed
your entire life of the best part of
your life i it was funny because um the
other night when cambodia won his uh his
big match and afterwards he said
i thought of what customarto said to
muhammad ali
in that um hit him with a big right hand
early on and get that respect
and i thought of you straight away i
thought i bet you teddy's enjoying that
there that someone still remembers the
old the old school ways yeah that caught
that caught my attention i just did an
interview with cambosis of fine man
champion man champion fighter
they connect they connect they're not
singular usually i told them i said you
really perk my ears
when i heard you uh talk about my mentor
as soon as i heard that i said oh this
is
this is this is interesting
and um this is a smart man
to search out that kind of information
anything that can help you
uh in the arena that you're going in a
difficult arena very lonely arena
a very dangerous arena
an arena of many many dimensions
emotionally spiritually physically
technically
so
good for him
that he searched out that information to
help him and it did help him uh if it
didn't help him in a physical way it
helped him in a
mental way which was 75 percent of this
business because
it helped him
think
of something that would work it gave him
confidence
you know when you're out in that ocean
of fear because we're all in it we're
all in it some people don't admit it but
it's okay they want to call it something
else they want to call it nervousness
butterflies
you know you want to call it uh
anxiety fine no problem but it's fear
it's the world of fear and it's who
lives in it better
and who controls it better
and when you're in that ocean
of such a thing
we all need a life raft
we all need something
to get us
to land and that was part of the
something that got mr campos who's now a
world champion that's part of what got
him to land
that he could believe in that he could
know that he could understand that
and
he could see it as something
that was real
that was part of truth
yeah proven uh proven to work there was
a precedent for it and cuts always told
me
that
world champions were geniuses
that was his genius that's part of his
genius that cuz is right
that he was able
to not only search that out not only to
discover something that could help him
but to understand that it could help him
and
so
that was part of what got him through
his journey there like i said it got my
attention
and we talked about it on a on a podcast
on the interview when we did it with him
where it was
it was perfect because
it really matched up
with why cuss gave that advice to the
great muhammad ali when he was fighting
the great george foreman because ali was
supposed to have no chance he was a 7-1
underdog cambodia's was a 13 to 100 dog
but ali was supposed to have no there
was actually people that were in fear of
his life that actually said you could
you could get killed
fighting this monster
you know uh that's just toppling
buildings toppling people he's
my grandson uh always plays king kong
and he he makes me godzilla so
we're he's four years old
i'm blessed i got three grandchildren he
he he's he's my buddy he doesn't even
call me papa anymore he calls me
godzilla i don't know how much longer
that's gonna last
hopefully hopefully there is an end to
it and
so i'm familiar with that with godzilla
and king kong and all these great
creatures foreman was all of them
i mean foreman was the boogeyman he was
supposed to have no chance foreman was
bullying guys fallen was going to go
right through guys it had gone right
through the great joe frazier and other
guys that were put in front of him
you know he had just beaten the great
joe frazier this
i mean obviously lopez had just beaten
the great lomachecko
there was a lot of similarities and
again
he was just an afterthought he was just
a name
you know he was just
you know a number
a number to the next victim that's what
he was supposed to be so he he needed a
little something
and that little something it really made
perfect
perfect sense
because
what cuts his message to foreman i mean
tally against foreman was
look this guy doesn't respect you well
let's go to lopez lopez said i'm blowing
them out in one round that's not
respectful okay so there it is
same thing so
car said told ali look this guy doesn't
respect you
and
he thinks he's just going to go in and
destroy you
and things that you're afraid of them
like everybody else to a certain degree
you're probably going gonna flee from
him whatever but it's it's gonna be
it's gonna be easy work at the same time
lopez
kind of represented a bully
you know kind of like the bully i see
you after school
and i'm going to kick the crap out of
you
and it ain't going to take me long so
very similar
and he had to send a message and god
said you got to set a message to this
guy you got to go out there in the first
round you got to hit him go across the
ring hit him with right hand let him
know tonight's different
tonight is not your night tonight
you are not in charge i'm in charge
things will not be the way they were in
the past i am here to win
i'm not here to survive i'm not here to
get a check i'm here to win
oh my goodness
cambos has sent that message
oh so succinctly
so beautifully so strongly and the
message was well received certainly was
and uh
he hit the deck and um
for me personally watching such a great
performance to know that that young
australian lad who was supposed to be
another number
had actually been
a student and done his research and done
his history work and used lessons that
other great fighters have used it just
made me appreciate it even more
it as it should yeah as it speaks to the
person you are
that you would appreciate you would you
would appreciate such things understand
such things
go below the surface so so when i was
researching your life especially uh
the early years there were some
surprises in there because you come
across as such a good dude you clearly
want to help people because you've
devoted so many years of your life to
training and teaching
students
but early on in your life you were not a
good guy or at least you weren't acting
like a good guy
and
coming from a background where your
father was a doctor that really
surprised me because
usually someone who comes out of a
family where
father's a doctor
the kids usually follow in those same
footsteps but you didn't you seem to be
on your own
destiny in your own way so what what
kind of happened there we all search for
things you know
and um we're on the lookout for
something
you know
call it love cortex whatever you don't
have to be from the projects you know
you don't have to be from poverty
to be poor
uh you know we we we draw up these
images where
it makes for good story telling and and
it listen it's true to it
but
it becomes
the poetic way it becomes you know the
the reading way the the way of novels
the way of again stories where the kid
comes from
the bottom of the bottom the bottom of
the barrel
you don't have to be in the bottom of
the barrel to be in the bottom of the
barrel
it's what
it's what you feel like
it's what you feel you need it's got
nothing to do
really
with your surroundings
it's got to do internally with what is
what you feel
and what you don't have
you know you could be in the greatest
neighborhood in the world
and you could be starving for things
i didn't know any of this stuff i'm not
smart enough
but as you get older
you recognize things
if you got a half a brain in your head
and um
you start to understand things
when i was young
[Music]
my father was the man
it wasn't mickey mantle was a willie
mace it wasn't
i love muhammad ali i lost 120 on him uh
when i was 12 years old in school and i
had to find a way to pay it back
pay your debts
i learned that lesson i learned that
lesson when i was 12 years old pay your
frickin debts or don't make a bet and i
found a way to do it wasn't easy those
guys were my heroes i didn't even know
what a hero was i had no idea if you if
you
you'd have to put webster's dictionary
in front of me and i'd read it and say
oh is that what it's supposed to be but
i didn't feel i didn't know what it was
except my father and i again i didn't
relate it i didn't
um
[Music]
internalize it and
articulate it out to be
oh he's my hero
he was just a guy that was he could do
anything
he left early in the morning he came
home late at night
and he saved people he made people that
were broken and fractured he made them
whole
he went into the projects to deliver
babies
he went to places that no other doctors
went
and he didn't go there for money
he got paid
but not like some of the other doctors i
mean he
half his case during the course of the
day might have been for free
i mean he did house calls who was 80. he
didn't charge
why you do it because
these people didn't even have the means
to get to an emergency room back in
those days there was no
obamacare there was no hmos there was
none of that stuff there was a clinic
somewhere probably not in the best
neighborhood in the world
that i hate to say you might be worse
off when you're left there or not better
off
like i said he went places that it was
dangerous to go just to help people to
make them better
without getting paid
most of the time or a lot of the time
he built a hospital that had 22 beds in
it so people could get proper hospital
care that wasn't getting it
because they couldn't get it they didn't
have insurance they didn't have
those things didn't exist they didn't
have the money
and um he absorbed the cost the people
that had money
uh
obviously that helped pay the bills and
the rest of it
he absorbed my only way of being around
my father
was to go to the office or to go on
house calls so i did
that's what i did because the model used
to say you know you learn things through
osmosis well i think it's true
you learn things through
example
i
felt things through osmosis
with my father i don't know if it's
called empathy for for people i don't
know what it's called but
i i felt something and but more
importantly i felt that i needed to be
around him and i couldn't be around him
that much
and as i got older
[Music]
it took me
to the wrong places
i'm making no damn excuses everything i
did i did i was selfish i was stupid
um
[Music]
i was all those things
when i say selfish because i just wanted
what i wanted
i want to be around my father i wanted
him to be at the games i wanted him to
be but he couldn't be i was too stupid
to understand that at that age too way
too dumb
because he had other things to do that
were a little more important
but not to me and you know that's part
of the selfishness but as a kid that's
what happens sometimes i guess and
so
i
in my infinite wisdom which of course
i'm saying tongue-in-cheek
but
the genius that i was i started to
figure out as a because i was going on
households when i was nine years old 10
years old 11 years old
and
even even eight
so i started to figure out as i got
older as i became a teenager
and i wanted to be around i started to
figure out how you
how you could be around dr atlas more
you know without again with i didn't
articulate this in my head and say oh
consciously but i realized later that to
some degree that's what was happening
that i figured out that all the people
that got his attention
because that was the mission how do i
get his attention
and then i figured out all the people
that get his attention are the broken
ones the fractured ones the injured ones
the messed up ones
the sick ones
so
i got sick
i got fractured
i got messed up
i got lost
and you know i went on this
i went on this
journey i found people
to hang out with to grow up with
uh in a tough area
where
some of them were looking for things too
and
it gave me comfort
gave me the family
i wanted or i thought i needed
and
it also gave me the purpose
to be around dangerous things
that
could wind up getting me
a house call
with dr atlas
so to speak and um
i'm fighting in the streets i'm doing
some robberies i hate to say it because
i'm not
proud of it but
i do feel good about where i got because
tomorrow once told me teddy don't matter
it doesn't matter how long it takes
a guy to become a champion or to get to
that place as long as he gets there
as long as he gets there
and
and that's what i go by
according to my family
and some friends i i
i kind of got there
and i'm thankful
and
everyone has a journey i always tell
fighters that are under my
my guide i say you know yeah but teddy i
i shouldn't have lost that fight i
should i
now i'm not gonna be i said
everyone has a different
journey
your journey was to lose that fight so
you could win the next one the one that
is going to get you there but that's
part of your journey but why teddy why
why why should i ever get robbed or
whatever it was
because
that is what's necessary for you not him
not somebody else but for you
to get what you need to get
and to learn what you need to learn to
get down the rest of the road of this
journey
i was i remember one time going to a
fight
a boxing match i remember my coach
he was putting vaseline on me and he put
his hand on the back of my head
and i kind of moved and he said what's
the matter i said nothing
and he looked and i i had stitches in my
head he said what the [__] is this
i said ah it's
it's nothing it's yeah what do you mean
it's nothing you got freaking stitches
in your head
you know i had obviously gotten it on
the street a few days earlier
and i wasn't living the right life but i
was still fighting and then
finally it went to the place where those
things wind up going
you either
get killed or you're going to jail you
know
i mean there's not too many other places
that's taking you
and uh i got to the place where it
looked like i was going to jail and
kevin rooney had already left the
neighborhood and went up st just won the
gloves in 1975 he went up state to trade
with the great custom auto
and
four months ahead of me and i i'm in
trouble on the street he took he went to
carson said i want to bring my friend up
here and he said who is he there he's a
kid teddy atlas he's a
he's a fighter but he's in trouble and
i'd like to
i'd like to keep him up here he's going
to be going to trial
and i like to keep him up here
can you trust him you know is he he's
not going to rob the tv sets or nothing
is he and he said no
don't worry and i got up there because
got involved in my life he helped me
um you know i
i had no problem being there for
for other people i had trouble
understanding how to be there for myself
but i know i'm not alone in that world
teddy you've i've got a few questions
about everything you've been telling me
don't don't ask me open-ended questions
like that because no you're great you're
great because i just i try to get to the
end of them i'm absorbing it i'm taking
this all in so a couple of things i was
wondering
um i believe the picture behind you is
your father yeah that's it uh which
shows the admiration and love that you
have for him
and clearly
you know maybe not getting
uh what you were wanting from him was
part of the reason that drove you to do
some things he did
i don't know if this is the right way to
phrase it but did you forgive him for
the way you were feeling because
obviously
a child just wants their dad and
you know sometimes working through that
from person experience can be quite
tricky
i only think of one thing
does he forgive me
because i let him down
[Music]
i'm a doctor's son i'm not supposed to
be on a front freaking page of some
newspaper robbing somebody okay um you
know i'm not supposed to be uh
i'm not supposed to be coming to his
office like i'm
like i'm some star like i'm freaking uh
uh
like a mick jagger and i'm walking in
bleeding like a pig and with a friend
and and i think i'm going to go to the
front of the line because i just got hit
with a tie-in
i'm going to go to the front of the line
to get fixed up so i could go back
outside and keep doing the crap i was
doing and you know
i hope i hope he forgives me because
and and he understands that i got to the
right place
and that um
you know that i'm thankful because i
remember that day when i walked in his
office with a friend you know
middle of the day fighting out in the
street and you know you learned things
i was getting my apprenticeship as a
future trainer i didn't know that
because yeah you learned you know well
not just how to handle cuts but you
learn
that people
can be strong but they can be weak and
the ones you think are strong could be
the weakest
you know here's a guy i'm fighting three
guys right and one has to hit me with a
tie that's not strong
that's not strong it's not
it's it's not and and it's just later on
i'm like yeah if i see a guy who's
strong he might be very weak
he might be very weak and i might have
to make them stronger as a trainer it
really does it teaches you things so
you don't know it i mean you just know
you're getting freaking sutures put in
your freaking skull but when
when i walked in that day
like thinking you know i i'm special i
could go right to the front of the line
because my father you have to wait five
hours to see dr alice that's how many
patients he had maybe six hours so
i i go walking in the patient or the
nurse says oh my god come on and of
course she's taking me in and he comes
out of i'm
i'll never forget he walks out of one of
his offices you know he has a bunch of
rooms one of the rooms he walks out in
the hallway he sees me bleeding and
without hesitation he says hap go on
have him go in the waiting room and wait
like everyone else
that'll put you that'll soap you up baby
yeah
such a dodd move though isn't it it's
like yeah you're gonna get a lesson a
day boy yeah and then the lesson wasn't
over then when i finally get to hey
listen he still gave me the family
discount um uh break because i already
waited i only made about two hours so so
i still got the family break but
when when i finally got in there
and and
and she's shaving my that part of the
head you know to get the sutures in
there and and then she's standing there
with a needle of novocaine
he looks at her the poor woman he looks
at he says what's that for and she's
like trembling she's like uh it's
you know it's for the it's it's for the
pain and he says pain
he doesn't want that
if he's going to live like this
he wants to know how it feels
and i and me you know you could imagine
well i said yeah i don't want that what
are you giving me that for
you know because i'm embarrassed i'm i'm
i'm embarrassed i'm embarrassed in front
of my hero i don't know he's my hero but
i'm embarrassed in front of willie mays
i am and i'm like yeah i don't
i don't freaking want that
what's the matter with this lady
so
they're all lessons
but
that's the answer to your question i i
just hope
i just hope he's up there you know and
he forgives me and he and he says hey
you know he's doing good i'm running a
foundation now a charity foundation
called the dr atlas foundation 25 years
and
what we do is
we
you know seven days a week 365 a year
we help people that fall through the
cracks
you know it's it's a mother with five
kids and one of her kids gets sick and
she she has to miss work and uh next
thing you know she's behind on the rent
and stuff and she's gonna be put into a
shelter shelters are not good around
here i hate to tell you they they can be
very violent and she's got to be put
into a shelter we step in and we'll pay
the three thousand dollars for the rent
and this and that uh to get into a place
uh just temporarily to where we're you
know we're no heroes but we get you from
point a to point b
and we're stepping back now that 3 000
it might as well be 30 000 for these
people we're talking about that's that's
everything is relative that's what
counts so
and and then she doesn't have to go or
we'll put handicapped vamp you know or
we'll we're we'll get a
we'll pay for the cancer medication that
that uh a poor family had a young kid
with cancer and the insurance paid for
the
paid for the surgery which could have
been enormous enormous but the way that
again joking around infinite wisdom who
the hell knows who comes up with these
ideas but the cancer medication that has
to be bought once a month is not covered
by the insurance and it costs 1200 a
month guess what might as well be again
12 000 a month they can't pay it we pay
it you know and uh they need to fly out
of state uh to get a treatment program
that makes more sense for their their
you know if their sick child we fly them
out of state uh
we we run a food pantry
for people that hey they can't get
enough food
uh so we run in center programs and
at-risk schools dangerous schools where
the yeah
it's dangerous i mean schools should not
have metal detectors all right
and so we go into these schools and we
tell the kids look
practical practical
it was practical what my father did he
got in a car he went to your house it
was practical
we we tell them
if you improve your behavior if you
start caring give a damn about who you
are that's the problem they don't care
who they are because of the way they're
brought up and what they're not brought
up with and they don't have fathers
i mean the truth is the truth
and if you try to avoid that truth you
can't get to the place you got to get to
to help these kids
so
we understand the truth so we go in
there we tell them look if you start
taking ownership over who you are start
caring who you are and it shows in your
behavior and controlling your behavior
we'll have your teachers will watch you
over the next month and a half two
months whatever the marketing period is
and they will put you on a list and if
you're on that list we're coming back
with 200 tickets to the for the yankee
game the mets game the knicks the nets
whatever it is and we got buses we're
gonna we're gonna bring the buses to and
you're gonna get chosen you're gonna go
to a game and you know what
it makes a difference it does
why why
first of all they got nobody doing that
so that's number one why and number two
why
it gives them a reason
to care about what they're doing
to care about who they are
so we
so i hope my father sees that i really
do i hope he sees that
and you know he could say hey
no one hear me get mad at me you want to
know why he was such a humble guy if you
ever talked about him doing something
special you know what he would tell you
nah
i didn't do anything i didn't that
wasn't special
that was just doing what you're supposed
to do well teddy
do you believe in magic yeah povetkin
magic uh mystery but it works for all of
us and and just as it worked for
povetkin you know you're you're getting
people talking about you and doing great
things now and for that reason i'm sure
your father is very very proud of me and
uh i felt like when you were telling me
about what you were lacking when you
were a young guy
it was kind of that purpose that your
father had he had his purpose he'd found
that but you just hadn't found your
thing yet
and as you got older
um boxing obviously was was that purpose
this was what your destiny was
and you mentioned earlier uh customardo
brought you into his his circle which uh
i don't know if you believe in fate but
it does it it felt like the perfect
thing that happened to you because
you've clearly
taken so much from the great man
can you tell me what it was like when
you first met him in and what that was
like i never knew what it was like or
what it was supposed to be like to meet
a legend
[Music]
like i didn't know what a hero was
i didn't know what a hero talked like i
didn't know what a hero looked like
i didn't know i was living with but i
was living with a hero my father but i
didn't know how to describe it how to
articulate it how to
you know break it down
[Music]
but
i was just told that this guy was a
legend this guy
he fought the mob he did
he che you know he went against the
powers to be
he had the heavyweight champ of the
world with the heavyweight champ of the
world there was only one
instead of a hundred
and uh
and he was you know
he to get the heavyweight champ he had
to take his own route
he had to figure it out
you know he had to overcome so many
obstacles and
you know and he was a guy who would
never get on a plane and never fly and
his cars told me he said teddy
i don't fly
flying flying is
for the birds and for the angels which i
am neither
and uh
so here's a man who when when he had a
fight in europe with uh
you know with paterson or whatever he he
would have to take a ship over there a
ship
to get there
and then he isolated himself
he was
he had taken himself out of
out of the world
and he was living in catskill
you know
isolated from everything no longer with
the big times why do you think he did
that
different reasons one
he had a bad breakup
so to speak with the sport of boxing
um
there was the keith alpha investigation
where
he was going up against the ipc who ran
madison square garden and
gymnaris and
all these people that were at that time
controlled by
the gangsters if you will
um
you know frankie cobble blinky palermo
frankie carpo was known as mr gray
and
you know they they ran to a great extent
back in those days they had a lot to do
with the running of boxing and the
running of who was going to fight for a
title
sometimes who's going to win it
and um
cuss upset that apple cart to a certain
extent
i mean as soon as he won a title with
patterson when when they knocked out
archie moore
he he made a announcement the next day
that they would no longer fight ibc
fighters that meant mob control fighters
that's kind of what it meant
and and so
that's a brave move
yeah i mean i don't know
if it's fair to say he got chased out of
the sport or just walked out of the
sport um maybe a combination but
he left the sport
he went up to
catskill new york and he lived up there
he wound up he had a deal with jimmy
jacobs who owned big fights incorporated
was partners for bill caton later on
became the managers of mike tyson
and they
you know they they paid the bills and he
was basically i mean he was you know i
mean the truth is the truth it's not a
bad thing but to say what it was
i mean he was in a bad role for the
first half of the day usually
because
there was no fighters up there there was
very few
and he was um
he was on you know he was like the song
the beatles made the man on top of the
hill he was he was this great figure who
had been great in his time
and he was
retired or semi-retired
to the hills
to the country did you feel sorry for
him a little bit when because no no i
didn't feel sorry i just tried to
understand them i was like this
here's
it's kind of like
kevin wrote all my information was
coming from my friend kevin rooney my
childhood friend and he's telling me
he's a genius he's this special man and
and he's you're going to learn so much
from him and
you know he's the
you know he's the wizard of oz uh he's
he's just and then i get up there and
he's in a wardrobe i i mean he's in a
bathroom but you know two o'clock in the
afternoon i'm like
this is the guy where is he
where is he
so yeah so i had a lot of figuring out
to do you know i i had i'm thinking
jesus
rooney's told me all these things but
the guy don't seem to be that guy
but then with time i understood with
time i understood his his wisdom his
disconnect from the world
his beliefs
but most of all
his understanding of human nature and
now human mind
i understood that and
also his complete devotion
to the sport of boxing like he told me
one day you know we got very close he
told me what they said listen teddy
i
be before you get married make sure you
pick the right woman and i said yeah of
course
no no you don't understand
in this sport
you
it takes complete dedication and the
reason i never got married
is i could never
be honest and say i've given full
dedication to another person
when i knew that the person that came
first in my life was boxing how many
people gonna tell you that
you know what i mean how many people are
gonna you know self-search themselves to
to understand that
that that need for that commitment that
truth to that
um not too many not too many and
you know
it was funny because he
he would say to me
you know when you're
you know when you're older and you're in
you know whatever 70s that whatever
you're older someday meanwhile i'm an 18
year old kid with him 19 year old i
can't even think of when i'm going to be
21 where i could legally drink so he's
like uh you know and you're doing this
about and and you're training and i'm
thinking to myself i'm not going to be
training fighters when i'm
70 years i cut this
you know i i didn't sign on i didn't
sign on here for you know uh
life and death the whole oh yeah she did
oh yes
i wouldn't know that so at such an early
age looking at you
you know what he told me he put me in
the gloves
and i you know i i won the gloves i was
lucky i i i was i won the gloves and i
was a good one you were on the go is
this the golden gloves uh yeah yeah yeah
yeah i read up on that
so anyway i went to gloves whatever and
then but i had an injury so long story
short but he didn't let me overcome the
injury now
it's got to be explained if i'd make a
strong statement like that
i mean we went to doctors and of course
the best was my father and i had a
problem but
that wasn't the end all to my career
because said it was but he wanted it to
be he was a genius he he had nobody up
there and he saw something according to
him
that i was a i was a born teacher
and and he said you can
and he spent every day then trying to
convince me
to be a trainer he said listen i gotta
pass this on i gotta pass this on
and you this is what this is what you're
meant to be you're a teacher yeah you
could have been
you could have been a fighter but that's
that's that's yesterday
today
let's concentrate on being a teacher
being a trainer where you could be part
of other people's lives you can help
them get to their dreams to their tests
and instead of being only
part of your dream you can be part of
thousands of people hundreds of people's
dream and help make that come true
instead of just one
and you could be
a person that has many titles with many
people
instead of just one you know he kept
driving at home driving at home driving
at home and um i guess it got home i
guess it took a while like somebody very
wise once told me
you have plans for life and life has
plans for you
and it's true
things change and a kid walked into the
gym you know we brought him in the gym
he was 12 years old his name was mike
tyson you might have heard of him and uh
and it changed things you know
four years after me training him
things happen and
me and cuz had to say goodbye to each
other it was it was the destiny it was
it was it was a journey we had no idea
that was going to be the journey
uh at the time but
that was gonna be the journey well you
created something amazing together
and if you are um gonna team up
on a boxer and it felt like um
you know cuss was uh the
the old wise head and you were sort of
the the one who had the energy to keep
up with my tyson all day when when i was
watching some of those old sessions that
was destiny it really did feel that way
and um
i guess one of the questions i'd like to
ask you about course
how do you think his words are so
tattooed on your brain because
you know even before we even started
talking about him you quoted him twice
and it's very rare that a human
can leave a mark
on people the way it costed on so many
people not just you but obviously mike
tyson
and as someone who's never met the guy
it always fascinates me of how's this
guy's words
so powerful that they've stayed with
people long after he's passed away well
he mocked my life i mean he was a mark
on my life he was a
influence on my life at at a particular
time
that i needed an influence on my life
that's the key
i'll tell you another thing he was very
good at
talking and articulating things because
and my father was the opposite he could
be brilliant at it but he didn't talk he
just did
and what gets lost in a translation
is that taking nothing away from cause
who i love
but i was angry at
but i love
and i understand better now
because i was angry he you know he
he took the side of the fighter me and
cuss were partners i was training all
those fighters i mean when i got there
was an empty gym
and
we made it not empty anymore
and cuz would come to us once a week
maybe once every two weeks depending on
how he felt just to
see what was going on
and he would give me what i needed you
know
like giving a lion uh raw meat he he he
gave me what i needed he would he'd come
in the gym i'll never forget he he
wasn't there for two weeks he walked in
and and we had nobody then we had 10
kids 20 kids 30 kids four and i got all
these kids coming to the gym and i'm
developed i'm you know and i'm taking
them down to bronx to get fights and get
experience and put in tournaments that
were winning tournaments and he would
come in after a few weeks they say my
god
teddy atlas
is creating fighters here champions you
know and it would lift me up i could i
could float i wasn't getting paid a dime
i wasn't getting paid a dime
i i couldn't even afford a cheeseburger
some days and
yet i felt rich
i felt i felt rich like i said earlier
you don't have to you don't have to be
poor to be poor
and you don't have to be rich to be rich
and i i could have floated out i i was
like oh man yeah look at what he's doing
he's creating
champions look at this and
that's all i needed but meanwhile the
guy
behind the curtain
who was paying 50 let's get it right it
wasn't you know five thousand it was 50
measly dollars guess what it wasn't
measly in those days
it wasn't measles back in the 70s and he
was paying
my father was paying my rent and board
fifty dollars a week two hundred dollars
a month and without that i'm not there
and without that i'm not here
wow and
and you know and then talk about all the
great things cause said
and they were all right and they were
great
my father was doing them
you know being a professional because
would say to me being a pro teddy atlas
remember this it's doing what you said
you were gonna
do it's doing what you're committed to
doing no matter how you feel you wake up
you're sick you go to work you wake up
you're throwing up you have diarrhea you
go to work
you
somebody dies you go to work
i mean it got deep it got deep and you
do your job you're in a fight you got a
broken hand you use the other hand
yo that's a professional
you you do
what's supposed to be done no matter how
you feel
so he's telling me this
and who's doing it
my father
when it when i was a kid he would put a
white pill under his tongue i didn't
know what it was
it was a nitroglycerin because his heart
was skipping a beat
but he kept going he kept going
he he had surgery
when he was already
in his 70s
and what does he do he waits to my
mother who does this
he waits for my mother goes away to
daytona beach on a vacation and he's
alone and he and this way
he can plan a surgery that he has to get
and he gets the surgery has somebody
drive him down he goes down to
philadelphia gets the surgery supposed
to stay a few days doesn't
lays in the back of the driver's car
comes back
and the next day
he's in his office working on a couch
because he's in too much pain to stand
up
taking care of his patients
and my mother don't know because she's
not a florida that's why
he waited that's a professional
that's a professional call him a crazy
man if you want fine
that's a professional
and so cuss is telling me all these
things
and as time goes on i'm saying
[Music]
my father
and so it was a
it was a very very
strange and
powerful
set of uh
crossing over
of of a mixture
of different
[Music]
just different alternate
energies
and um different alternate
sources
of
of wisdom and life
that were coming to me one was coming to
me from this great custom model
that was kind of
drawing the picture
magnificently
but then the other one quietly in the
background was coloring it in
every day
while you were sleeping
so you wouldn't see them coloring it in
and then
one day you go and you see this picture
you say oh my god
it's so funny because um
well my mother passed away when i was
younger and the older i've gotten
the more i'm able to appreciate her
because of the wiser i get the more i'm
able to reflect back on her life and
look at it through
a different lens almost and go oh
now i understand and you and it's nice
to feel like you can still connect with
the parent in a different way entirely
even when they're not here
through that maturity that you're
gaining and through the bigger picture
and i totally understand what you're
saying there teddy and uh
the way you've described your father
what a guy what a man
your father was incredible when you say
that i feel good
and it makes me connect
to
to a saying from
from one of the cultures they call a guy
like that a mensch
i hear people say that to me once in a
while your dad was a mensch and you know
you don't have to really again you don't
have to go to webster's dictionary and
really define what match means
because when they connect it to life to
action
to how a person lived
you get it so when when somebody
described you know
a mensch
i understand my
father in my own private proud way was a
mensch because they described that as
somebody who was strong
somebody who
found a way to keep his word
when it wasn't the easiest thing in the
world to keep
you know to do what you said you were
gonna freaking do
my father you know how many times my
father went up on a house call at one in
the morning 12 o'clock at night uh doing
a house call you know why because
earlier in the day he told the patient
he'd be there but he couldn't get there
because he had so many other patients
until midnight until one o'clock but he
got there i'm on a house called my
father and you know i'm nine years old
whatever the hell i am and um we're
going down this road and we we never do
two house calls uh in a short period of
time so i noticed that it was the same
house we had done
uh
i don't know maybe a few days earlier
maybe a week earlier and i was surprised
so i said
this person must be very sick
it made sense because we're there and he
goes no actually she's she's pretty very
healthy
pretty healthy for her age she's
obviously she was very old
and
so we're pulling up and as well pulling
up i noticed there's cold out i noticed
that
again it was a tough area a poor area
but i noticed that this woman and she
was an old woman
she had come out with an overcoat over
her
and and she was outside so i thought oh
my god
she couldn't even wait inside like she's
you know obviously waiting to see him
and um
so i said
well if she's not
you know she's not sick if she's not
that sick why are we here and the rules
just so you know he never told me this
was a rule but it was not professional
for a son to go in the house or into the
apartment
um for a house call so i would always
wait no i never questioned it i never
tried to get out i always understood
somehow that you you stayed in the car
but he would leave the keys there and he
would say if it gets cold enough you
could start it up
he's getting out and there was a routine
he would get out of the car and he would
open up the back door to get the doctors
back because he didn't have one of these
little
tiny doctor bags he had a big one he had
a big black doctor's bag that had a lot
of stuff in it
and
he
so he opens up the back door and he's
taking the doctor and that's my chance
to talk again
real quick i know the routine so she he
just told me she's not that sick so
then then why why are we here says
she's lonely and loneliness is his
sickness
and he shut the door
and i had to wait till he got back from
the house call to get the other answer
what do you do for somebody who's not
sick but they're lonely and you say
that's a sickness you know so what do
you do
so he comes back in he had a my father
didn't say much but he had a great sense
of humor
and and he was one of those guys who
could make fun of himself
and he and
he and make it sound pretty good
and he so he comes back he opens up the
back door he puts the bag in he gets in
the front door and i'm waiting
and i say so what do you what what do
you do for
and he says
i let her make me a cup of tea
and i listen
and let her tell me what a great doctor
i am
[Laughter]
i'm glad i would say oh that's that's
what you do
yeah and then he told me later on
and i didn't understand until i got
older he said i give her
a placebo
so i never understood later on
he told me i gave her sugar pills
and then of course i understood placebo
sugar pills i got it i understood but
that was the thing to me that made him
i don't know
i guess that's part of why i felt the
way i felt here's a guy going out there
doing an extra house call with a woman
who doesn't really need medicine doesn't
need no antibiotics
but she needs somebody
somebody to listen
because she had no family and that would
have been in an era where things like
mental health and depression weren't
really
fully understood to the way that they
are today so you know very he was
obviously ahead of his his time in that
regard um yeah you mentioned earlier uh
this 12 year old kid comes into the
boxing gym
the story of mike tyson and cuss and
your involvement is legendary and uh i
went back and i i looked up some of the
footage
of my tyson in it like a youth boxing
tournament and you're there
with a little bit of facial hair and uh
and darker hair and and but
mike must have been about 15 but he
looked massive for a 15 year old and he
was dropping these kids like uh you know
flies
and um what was really interesting was
obviously now i know you as this big
passionate speaker
but with mike mike was uh crying before
a main event very upset very looking
like he was just struggling in the
moment even though
this was you know
seemed easy for him
and you the way you were talking to mike
you were very quiet you were very calm
you were very gentle with him
and you know when he won the fight he
leapt into your arms and hugged you and
clear that there was a lot of love back
then and i just wondered sort of
well what made you take that kind of
approach with mike and how how how were
you with mike in terms of coaching him
and talking to him in that way was it
always like that or did you change it or
it was louder sometimes
yeah it wasn't always
so spoken it was loud it was what it
needed to be
i'm not trying to make myself smart or
i'm a professional trainer i'm supposed
to know at that time of course
i was training pros too even though i
was a young kid but um i'm supposed to
know what the hell i'm supposed to say
at the at the right freaking time with
the who that person is
i'm supposed to know that
and i think i think i knew that i mean i
don't get
credit or medals for that or whatever
doesn't
as people say it's this that whatever
but i was i was doing what needed to be
done at the time with that particular
situation with that particular person
knowing what he needed knowing where he
was emotionally where he was mentally
you know and that's what he needed
something louder was not needed at that
point if it was
uh
you would have heard it
it was another fight sometimes
but at that time he needed
comforting but he needed strong comfort
he needed understanding he needed
he needed a partner
that was with him that understood where
he was and where he was going
and
i needed to be that i understood that so
i i was that you were perfect actually
you were absolutely perfect
for obviously you were young back then
but obviously we it's easy to connect
the dots now looking back but
mike um he looked like a bit of a
tortured soul even in the footage there
and the way you were calmly and gently
handling him and keeping him cool
before the violence
um it was the perfect balance to what
was clearly going on in this young man's
head and then afterwards it shows you
ringing cuss up going hey we broke a
world broke a new record cuss is
delighted you're happy
um
and everything seemed so great a i was
wondering
what it was like watching the the birth
of of the beast um in mike tyson but
then
why it went from him jumping into your
arms and celebrating with you in those
lovely moments to
you guys not speaking anymore and you
having to leave what was it like to
to be part of this to see
this phenomena if you will
this protege if you will
develop into this
into what everybody hopes they could get
a
a great fighter
a dominant fighter a special fight even
the most honest answer
[Music]
i can give you is the one you probably
wouldn't expect i wasn't in a train
seeing a countryside saying wow how
beautiful this is
i was just
driving the train
going to where we had to go
so
it wasn't really a matter of me
being able to and i love to give myself
credit say oh boy i saw everything ahead
of time and
i was just doing my job day to day my
job was to take someone who was given to
me
my that responsibility and make them
into the best fight i could make them
into
and i was doing that job i was doing it
piece by piece brick by brick it was
like kind of like if you're a builder
and you're building a house i
i i knew
i saw
a picture of what the house had to be i
i understood that
but as i was putting those bricks down
laying those bricks day to day you know
hot cold out hot out whatever and i'm
laying those bricks and then putting a
mortar in between to make sure those
bricks stick i i i wasn't
i wasn't
you know each inch of the way saying oh
how it's getting closer to being this
this
beautiful piece of architect that it's
you know being uh the notre dame or it's
be you know being something with a
coliseum that the romans built i wasn't
i was just putting the bricks in
the way i felt i needed to put them in
and when every once in a while something
shifted
where i had to replace a brick i
replaced a freaking prick to me
if i made it more glamorous or more
romantic or more
credit to myself and seeing what was
i was just seeing each day he got better
at slipping a punch did he get better at
getting away from the right hand
did he get better at close in the
distance without getting hit
uh did he get better at putting punches
together
did he get better at becoming a body
puncher
did he get a little calmer each day and
more understanding of what i was
teaching him that's that's where my
focus was so when your focus is that and
it was concentrated and it was on all my
fighters that concentrated that's you
don't have the privilege or the pleasure
really to be saying
i'm developing
the next greatest
heavyweight of all time or the next joe
lewis or the next rocky mountain seattle
or the
i don't have the pleasure of that i
don't have the time for that i don't
know is that cause you can't allow that
because you have to stay so focused on
the process
yeah because nothing nothing is promised
it's it's what you make happen
and what you work at making happen
and
i got that from my father again
not verbalized
but osmosis
you know
he he didn't sit back and think of what
a great doctor he was or the
or how he's gonna
he he sat back
and
every day the phone rang and told him to
do a house call he did a house call when
when when a son came up in the morning
he went to work
and
he went to work and you know
it wasn't pre-ordained he went to work
and figured out when he was there that
his job every day was to make somebody
better
and and to administer whatever needed to
be administered as far as advice and
medicine i did the same thing i was a
professional box i was a boxing trainer
i was not a trainer coach would get mad
at me because said you're not a trainer
you're a teacher all right i was a
teacher
and every day my job was to go in there
and teach the next lesson eventually get
to that place yeah and then when you get
to that place then you can take a deep
breath then you can sit back then you
can say whoa that's pretty damn good wow
but you know what i was taught the way
through cuss for my father
it was funny i didn't even get that much
i got pleasure don't get me wrong but
when we got to that place it was like
okay now how do we get to the next place
so what was the the the place the
original moment i guess of because when
i watched mike tyson footage when he was
14-15 and he's hitting a heavy bag like
a
phenom you know like nothing i've ever
seen before in terms of power and speed
was there a moment where it sort of
it hit you like okay
world champion is coming here this is
going to happen
i don't know that i can tell you that
even though that seems like the thing i
should be telling you
because um
[Music]
i should be smart enough to see that
right but i was so consumed i think with
getting to the next moment because
because when we were knocking everyone
out
um at the end of the day
it was great it was beautiful
but okay the next thing for me was
see he drew too many head shots he got
to him but he should have went to the
body because he would have got to him 30
seconds earlier because if he went to
the body he would have he wouldn't have
wasted all those other head shots which
he got to him but if he wastes those
shots with a better fighter he'll get
caught in between oh okay okay okay okay
okay
you know i don't know if you understand
no i do i do like perfectionists and
high achievers
they don't smell the roses they're too
focused on getting to the next step and
the next step was just the next step
yeah that's all it was it was just
you know
like when he was knocking everyone out i
remember
i felt pretty good i came home because
me and cuss would sit down we'd go over
it
and um
and he started again i'm there you know
i'm not getting paid anything but like
cuz would remind me because
you're going to college
and this and you're not paying for
college
even though my father was paying a
little bit but it was what it was but he
said you're going to college that's
where you're going right now you're
going to college you're going to school
and it's going to pay off for you it's
going to pay later and you know
and
so when we would when we would sit and
talk
because
i'd feel pretty good but nothing beyond
what uh just that and i'd wait to hear
it and cuss would say to me
yeah he looks good for three rounds
but can he do it for
for four five six seven eight nine ten
um
no uh okay get back to work he didn't
say that but that
that that's that's what it was like
teddy teddy don't go
you know don't go reading your you know
premature um
great reviews yet the you know can he do
it can he do it for because that was
always the goal can he do it for 12
rounds
because that was always the goal
can he do because
consistency
yeah teddy he looks good for three but
he can can he do it for five six
and the truth would come home to me
no because i saw him when he when he
can't or or if he fights a real pro a
guy that he can't really catch clean
will he will he fall apart
will he start to deteriorate
uh
yeah i've seen signs of that
okay go back to work talk to you later
you know that kind of thing and you know
that was it wasn't verbalized again as i
say but
it was understood it was understood and
rightfully so you know you know how many
times cuss would come
again he wouldn't come to the gym every
day but
he'd come once a while when he knew
tyson was sparring he'd he would come
and so
he'd come and he watched and i was
developing all kinds of fighters big
kids too but
nobody could handle tyson not the kids i
mean they because he would touch them he
would hurt them i mean that was the
truth you know he was like one of those
guys because i love cuz
the scriptures because would say to me
teddy the old timers would say you hit a
guy this guy hits so hard he hits you on
top of the head he fractures your ankles
and and
and you know that was tyson he that was
him he did it to burbrick he hit him on
top of the head he fractured his ankles
so
you know i i was developing these these
kids i would sometimes let tyson move
with them and tell tyson you know you
have to control yourself
you know you can't hit him hard and
meanwhile he would touch them and and he
would still hurt them you know and and
he couldn't be trusted and i'm not
calling him a bad guy you have to
understand it's my
you're in my industry now when i say you
couldn't trust him i don't mean that
you know in a way you think of
necessarily when you say those words i
mean like he didn't have the maturity
and the confidence and the discipline
to truly hold back and still not get hit
and still not let the guy take advantage
of him he didn't have that yet
it takes a certain maturity and
confidence and seasoning
to be able to go
in there with a lesser fighter
and not hurt him and work with them
without having to hurt them so
i i i was i was in a conundrum
so
we started figuring out things
and then finally i remember i told cars
i said cause we gotta
and it was a little crazy because the
kid's 14 years old 15 years old we got
to pay somebody to spar with them and
cuss was like yeah
yeah
and that's crazy that's that's like
insane
but you know well i said yeah
so you know and then in those moments
when he was in there with men and he was
in there with more experienced guys
then
it's like cuz also used to tell me i
give credit to people who tell me things
i don't try to
but i did learn a few things on my own
also but you know and it's not just what
you learn it's where you take it like
said you're going to take what i gave
you and then you're going to take it to
your own places and eventually that
happened but i remember he used to say
teddy
with a fighter you want to check the the
heating system so i said
all right go ahead cuz give me the rest
of it
and you got me go ahead and he said well
if you go into a house and you're going
to buy a house don't you want to make
sure the pipes are good yes yes you
don't want to find out after you sign
the contract that
that there's holes in the pipe no
all right so you go in the house and the
owners of the house wants you to see it
in prime condition they put the heat on
70.
what do you have to do teddy i guess i
got to put the heat on 90.
yes
because then all of a sudden you see if
it's good plumbing or not because if
it's not
and this is custer's word so
ding ding ding ding little little ding
ding ding the little holes are going to
start popping out and you're going to
have problems and you're going to see
the plumbing's not good
same thing with a person
same thing with a fighter you want to
put the heat high and see if this these
holes start popping up so we put the
heat higher and sure enough he was right
i saw the holes popping up there was
there was no ting ting ting ting but
they were very obvious to a person if
you knew what you were looking for and
what you had to be looking for so i'm
gonna i'm watching and uh he's sitting
there with a guy he can't catch a big
shot and what does tyson start doing a
lot of people would have bypassed this
and said it was the other guy's fault
but
again cuss
wasn't paying me so he had to give me
something so he gave me a nickname the
young master again i could float right
out of the freaking gym i didn't have to
get
it's like he just gave me fifty thousand
i i'm the young master i'm the young
master holy crap i'm the freaking young
yeah you're the broke young master that
can't even buy a cheeseburger uh if you
get hungry but that didn't matter i was
the young master so
i'm in there and he's like basically
challenging me okay young master what do
you see
and
tyson's in there with this
guy eat big
and more developed more mature and
what's tyson doing he's throwing bombs
he can't knock him out they're being
blocked they're being slipped he can't
catch him the way he catches other guys
so what happens after
one two rounds he starts grabbing on the
inside but he does it in like cuss said
he does it in a clever way where he
doesn't he doesn't get blamed for it he
puts his hands behind the guy this way
he knows
that most
most people
in there with a big puncher like him
will take
what you give them as a way out what do
we mean by that when he put his hands
behind
you give an opportunity for the guy to
either
fight or
grab
most people will take the opportunity
because they got a little weakness
to grab
and as we would say me and cuss
make a silent agreement
that if you don't hit me
i won't hit you
so now it's not just a matter of me
teaching them how to slip bang bang slip
bang bang drop back a punch quick
but now i have to understand how to make
them better
mentally stronger
otherwise
we just got a bunch of beautiful bricks
put together
but we don't have the mortar to cement
to keep them in place so i got to do
that now so
i'm watching and sure enough he can't
knock the guy out after one or two
rounds he puts his hands behind the guy
on the inside where he should be
punching he should be finding ways to
create openings as i would always tell
him
no he puts his hands behind the guy
where he can't use his hands and what
does the guy do the guy takes a free
ride you're gonna give him a free ride
he's gonna take it and he grabs the
hands and he makes a solid agreement the
two of them you don't hit me i won't hit
you
what do i do cuz this watch
i jump in the freaking ring i jump in
the ring i slap his hands down
and i say no
no silent
agreements no free rides
drive your own freaking car when we get
home later on
that night god says
come over here and sit with me young
master again he might as well just
might as well have just given me a gold
cadillac yeah
because
i just that's what it was and
those were the lessons of
that
took place and needed to take place
at that point more and more more and
more um because that was the one
weakness tyson had
mentally you know he he that was the one
thing you couldn't give them
you could bring them to it you could
make them face it
and teach it and explain it
but
it wasn't like something that you could
stand there all day and teach them the
technique
it was something that he had to be part
of an understanding of an agreement of
with tyson obviously his childhood being
as tough as it was and
um is well documented and even later on
in life obviously he was seeing how
difficult he's found things mentally and
then to put a person like that into
superstardom it's a recipe for disaster
um
but i was wondering if when he was a
young kid
could you see
that pain and some of those issues
occasionally spilling out because
you know i've been in the boxing ring
and uh
the emotions will come out um
you know in in that ring especially you
saw weaknesses
you saw strength
power quickness speed and you saw
smartness
cerebralness where he understood what
you were teaching him
and he could put it to use and you saw
good instincts
he
understood what to do in certain moments
or what
instinctually
somebody else was feeling
i remember one time in an amateur fight
we're in a hallway it was for the
regionals to go to the nationals so it
was a big tournament
and we're in a hallway and he sees that
his opponent is in a hallway now in
front of him
and instinctually what does he do
genius
genius as cuss would say
he goes over and i'm watching him
usually this wouldn't have been noticed
but i'm watching him every second and he
goes over and he feels the wall i said
what the [__] is he doing and i could
see nobody else sees it but i see he's
feeling a wall and he tapped it
and then i said oh my god i know what
he's doing
he's he's he's not
he's not trying to be a laborer
but he's feeling to see
how hard and solid the wall is is it
concrete or is it just plasterboard
so now i'm watching i said this son of a
gun
i know what he's going to do
so he says shadow boxing right
and he waits to the other kids looking
and through the coin you know how you
could the corner of the uh your eyes you
could see if somebody's looking without
them seeing that you're looking well so
he does that and
he sees he's looking he goes over to the
wall
bang
he punches right through the wall
i said oh my god this fight's over
he he just ended this fight
this fight's over the kid
the kid looks sick the poor kid he
looked like like if somebody's getting
sick next to you on an airplane you got
to give him that airbag
i mean it's like he needed the hat back
i mean he needed that to throw up in and
i'm i almost felt sorry for the kid and
uh he you know he went in there he
dispatched of the kid well what was left
of him
what was i told custer story goes genius
genius he goes but now
you got a tougher problem
i said a tougher problem you just told
me i got a genius on my hands he goes
nah nah it's your job
you got a tougher partner
what is that you got to get him out of
that habit of depending on
someone else being weak for him to be
strong
that's your job the rest of the way
and that was my job so to to your
question what was it like
i would look and i say wow that's
i remember i'm
saying this saying
because
punchers are born they're not made no
matter how you improve them you can
improve them but they either born to be
a punch or they're not so
on one hand you see that you see the
truth of that that you have that
you have a guy who's born to be a
puncher
but then you also have that
other side
there's a guy who has weaknesses so
that's how i saw it every day
i saw it the way you again you might not
expect where yeah
i saw that if he
touched on top of the head he would
fracture your freaking ankles
but i also saw that his ankles were weak
if he didn't get his way
he would
he would go
he would start to disintegrate
so i i never could get you could never
get too high
or too full of
you know that
feeling that oh man
i got this guy i remember giving an
interview and that did you ever see that
documentary
yeah well anyway it was a documentary
done by michael martin he did a good he
hung out for a couple months um him and
his him and his uh
helper
leslie parks they they hung out for a
few months in catskill and they got
permission from from us
to and cause to stay up there and film
me in the gym every day for a while and
a lot of it again it was around the kids
that i was training but it was around
tyson and they followed us out to
colorado where we won the first
nationals and all that stuff
and uh watch me now that was the name of
it watch me now
so i remember giving all the way back
then how old was i i don't know
23 maybe
24.
i gave this interview and even then
i guess i understood obviously
i i told a story about how when we go to
these tournaments now
i hear people saying oh you got that
tyson
he's got that tyson that's teddy he's
got that tyson
he's a natural and the
that was the ins
if it wasn't said directly it was
intimated he's a natural he's just got
this guy who's unnatural he's a natural
destroyer he's got no fear he's a
monster he he he could not break
buildings down
he's a natural and i remember with no
talk from cars not just myself i
remember
when the interview was going on i said
to them
they don't know how wrong they are i
don't know if there's such a thing as a
natural out there
i know that there's such a thing in my
business as people that are born to
punch i get it
but a natural
i said i don't have a natural i don't
see a natural
i see
a great
subject to work with i see a great piece
of clay if you will that's that can be
molded into
some kind of special
special
you know
being if you will
spectacularly talented person to work
with
but i don't see any natural
if it was natural
he wouldn't start falling apart when
there was opposition when there was
something to overcome
when there was resistance
we're saying like athletically and
technically he picked things up very
quickly but mentally when the path of
resistance was there maybe he wasn't
such a natural he not maybe get rid of
that word
he wasn't
okay
not maybe
because
and here's here's the kicker
that part
is the most important part yeah
because
the bricks as i used the analogy earlier
are the bricks
but without the cement
they're just bricks they're not bricks
that stay in place when you walk on them
when you push them
when you punch them
and
that was the part that needed to be
there to cement
and
when people would say natural it started
to bother me
it actually would start to bother me to
the point where i set it to cuss one day
it's because you know we go there it's
almost like
it don't matter like people think anyone
could be like we just got to we like
this guy was delivered in the middle of
the night on a spaceship and a spaceship
got out of there before anybody could
take a picture of it and and we all we
have to do is go from place to place
where and he left
that's it we're just
yeah just drive them all right and get
gas in the tank and and customer laugh
and i said what are you laughing at
because you're getting annoyed it's
bothering you i said yeah a little bit a
little bit
and he goes
good good
now you know how important you are
he said
and that's all that matters
that's that's all that matters it
doesn't matter if the other people know
it and he said don't worry about it so
and and he was right i remember i would
say you know they don't and he would say
teddy listen he again he was giving me
something to keep me going
he said look that's your opposition out
there
you're going to be very successful in
this business
they don't understand these things that
you are getting to understand
that but that's your opposition don't
try to educate them
don't try to educate them he was funny
because he said first of all it's your
opposition you don't want to educate
them and second of all if you try you're
going to drive yourself as crazy as they
are
he and you know he would give me
something i remember kids when we were
one of the national tournaments on the
bus we'd get on the bus to go we would
stay by ourselves we were like we were
like alienated we were it was like me
and him and then everyone else on the
other part of the boat like they they
didn't even they were almost scared to
sit next to us and so we're on and tyson
wasn't missed on tyson he kept that
image he knew it would help him he knew
that it would help him so i remember
tyson would always have this stern look
on his face and and listen me and cuz
probably promoted it but he understood
it instinctually
on his own you know and he watched all
the old-time fighters that we had the
films off from jim jacobs and bill caton
so
he he would keep he would be like jack
dempsey like this one like that one you
know so this
particular day
he would
be like sunny listen
and that sultry that's serious that's
mean looking you know
uh
that that image
so we're on the uh it was the funniest
thing brian we're on a bus and you hear
these kids they're kids
meanwhile i got again i got the naturals
i got this monster the monster and and
they're all in the back and you hear
them talking and whispering and you can
hear them
that's
and finally one of them says
that's sonny liston's nephew
right there we knew we won the
tournament
we went we still had to go in there and
throw punches but the tournament was
over it was over brian and and so here's
here's the great part of it
tyson with this real serious look like
this
very mean serious look not an accident
for a split second he looked at me and
he went like this
[Laughter]
just a little peak of a smile there you
go we got him we got him we got him
teddy
teddy i'm um obviously
we
we can see how close you are in those
videos like you he really needed you
there's just no doubt about it and as
you've rightly described he he wasn't a
natural and he was coached hard and long
by you and um and the other guys but i
think the fact that that there was such
a falling out it
it must have been hard on you because
these these guys are your coach you uh
put blood sweat and tears into them
you're giving up your time to build them
into into as as curse said to live their
dreams and then one day
um you're disconnected and it it all
finished um can you sort of
describe
how that came about and how you were
left feeling afterwards
i felt betrayed by it wasn't so strong
with tyson was because
because he was my partner he was my
surrogate father he was my um he was my
mentor
and um
i trusted him he trusted me
we had it
we were working at the same thing
together i went up there you got to
remember he was retired somebody retired
whatever
and um
there was nobody in the gym we built
something i could say i built something
no that would be wrong we built
something we built something we built
something you know a funny thing cuz
would always say everyone's gotta get
tested fighters gotta get tested women
have to get tested friends have to get
tested all this stuff right he
articulated that to me because you think
somebody's uh he told me a story because
one time he comes from the bronx he said
one time a guy friend of his old friend
from the bronx came up to him very upset
what are you upset about and he said
what am i upset i'm upset that today i
found out that my friend of 20 years uh
isn't my friend anymore gus looked at
him and said let me ask you a question
yeah
how do you know he was ever your friend
what 20 i just finished telling you
because 20 years he's been my friend are
you didn't you hear what i said
did you hear what i said
how do you know he was ever your friend
was there ever a test something
uncomfortable something difficult
that he had to make a choice
between you and that
and the guy looks at him and says yeah
today
because there it is
there it is he was never your friend
today was the first day you found out
there was a test well after all of that
and all of that to me to me to me to me
to me there was a test finally
i don't know i'm a kid you know i'm a
young kid
but
i'm still a person and put a lot of time
in
and uh
he failed the test
if i go by everything he preached to me
everything he taught to me he felt the
test that was the first time he was
truly tested
between staying with a
future
great fighter possibly but it looked
like
and his last
his last stand so to speak for cuss he
was getting older do you mean like his
last chance at having a world champion
for like fight for him yeah his last
chance to have immortality
because believed in immortality
anyway
it was to me that was the test
it was because it was it represented
more than just a fighter it represented
everything comes to his whole life
to come down to one last great fighter
that he'll never be forgotten for
and he was right
and um
the only thing in the way of it at that
point
after what happened with me and tyson
was uh
[Music]
me
and he made a choice
i get it i'm older now i understand but
at that moment if you asked me to say
was i
this forgiving or understanding or smart
no i wasn't
i was angry i was hurt i was betrayed
you know to me the most important thing
in life is loyalty
most important i know there's other
things too but start with that
if you can be loyal you can be strong
and if you can be strong
you can be other things
for me it starts with loyalty and
there's a lot of there's a lot of
reasons to be loyal
but there's also
a lot of excuses not to be
and i thought coz found an excuse not to
be
he didn't pass the test and it hurt me
can i ask some questions about this
because because i am a little bit
confused because obviously
people fall out and people get become
friends again people make up so
i understand part of the story and for
those who don't know if you don't mind
me saying teddy uh from what i
understand there was a a a relative
um i don't was it a relative of you or
or cos himself no it was
a young girl
i had
it was my wife's sister okay
it was my sister-in-law she was 11 years
old
right and tyson said something
inappropriate to her
put his hands on it too but yeah he
didn't rape her he didn't rape her he
didn't
you know but the suggestion was that it
was going
he didn't sexually abuse her you know
again
you have a you have to tell the truth
but um but it was enough for me because
he suggested that was coming
and
you know
being the man you were you weren't going
to stand for that back then which makes
perfect sense to me i was not going to
stand for today either i got news for
you but exactly
any years i didn't get any better in
that area
and um
and yeah you you you found him
um and put a gun to his head
and told him
what the consequences would be if that
ever happened again
which i think everyone out there can
respect and knows that you know you were
well within your rights to feel the way
you felt and i don't think anyone would
blame you which is why
it is confusing that it was you who left
and i guess the thing i've never never
known or never fully understood is
why was that necessary was was were you
and because have things been bubbling
between you and mike before that moment
was he
was this a power play on his part or
yeah um yeah things were bubbling uh he
was testing me
testing boundaries a young kid that came
from where he came from he was testing
authority were you hard on him at times
do you think that's why you want it
i i was a teacher and
a teacher can be as you said soothing i
was his mentor i was just
i was his trainer i was his teacher i
was his guide in this world that he was
trying to get to
and
cuss was the supervisor
but i was the guy doing it as you said i
was soothing comforting supporting
supportive when we went to nationals in
that
documentary clip watch uh
watch me now but i was also i told you i
didn't hide it there was times i had to
be somebody else
and i was becoming some i was being
called to be somebody else more and more
as
he started to stretch the boundaries
of what he could stretch um
where he was in school he's supposed to
be in school he's threatening teachers
he's telling them
you know the teachers are telling them
get out of the lunchroom
uh it was 10 in a more whatever and go
to class and he's
throwing milk containers against the
wall towards them listen
he came from a tough area i know it he
comes from a tough background i get it i
understand it
but what do you succumb to that or do
you make him
and let him succumb to that or do you
make him get better than that you wanted
to make him a man yeah you do it the
right way but sometimes the right way
isn't the sooth talking it's a little
stronger than that sometimes and it's
action it's not talk this kid is smart
he's got an innate intelligence up the
street he knows when you're not gonna do
nothing when you're full of bs
and he knows when he's got the power
he was starting to get the power because
he was knocking guys out so i put him
out of the gym i i i got his attention
only way i could i put him out of the
gym because of this behavior
and cuss
started to take control of things he
never took control of before all the
incoming news the he got a relationship
with the principal vice principal
whoever the figure was at the school
and
he talked to that cuss was hey he was
convincing because his cousin was smart
and he told them listen this is a
special kid he could make this town
famous um and he started giving him that
stuff cousins had to do what he had to
do for himself too to survive i didn't
see that coming at first but but he's
undermining your authority and then
taking the the coaching power away from
you
which will then make mike lack respect
for you yeah listen it became the bad
cop good cop all right because became
the good cop i became the bad cop so i'm
in the gym with him i i put him out of
the gym
i explained to him you got to learn how
to control yourself outside the ring not
just inside the ring respect people
we're never going to have a success with
you if i allow you to continue down this
path
uh
you you can't do this
out of the gym and cuz started sneaking
them in the gym clothes never trained
them cuz never kevin rooney never
trained him now all of a sudden he's
putting him in the gym behind my back
with kevin rooney putting him through
the you know the moves that he was
taught already
because there was a tournament coming up
because didn't want him to miss the
tournament whatever
that became very that that was the end
right there i mean it took a little
while to get there
but that was the end so when when tyson
saw that this is a street kit that
recognizes strength and weakness
better than most
when he saw that he saw in the i didn't
have his power no more
he saw it i didn't i guess
so
i only have myself though
i still had myself
so he sees what cuss is undermining me
whatever you want to call it
and now he starts pushing the envelope
because i'm the bad guy i put him out of
the gym
so
he starts
he starts doing this to my
somebody in my family
it's not an accident
i i saw what he was doing
and um it led to what it led to it you
got to understand one other part
he was a ward of the state
he came to us when he was 12 years old
he had already been arrested 30 times by
time he was 11.
and he was in tryon it's a juvenile
detention center 30 miles outside of
albany not far from us and that's how we
got him
we had a responsibility the state had a
responsibility put him with somebody
responsible forget about the boxing part
we're as responsible as you can get when
it comes to that but put him with
somebody who's going to help him become
a better person help rehabilitate him
right and part of that was going to
school
getting along with people
developing
you know in a proper way so there was a
woman miss coleman i still remember her
name she was one of the case workers
there was we took a picture with her i
still have the picture and there was a
few others but
cuz was very smart so he's communicating
with whoever was he makes a relationship
and she loves what she's hearing from
him she's getting articles when he's
knocking guys out winning tournaments
and
it's he's she feels very good about it
what she's not getting
is that he's already been thrown out of
school
for his behavior
and that cuss made a relationship with
the principal and a lot of things are
not being reported
and they're not good things
she doesn't know obviously these things
and then
it heads to
where his trainer can you imagine this
his trainer puts a gun to his head
and listen if you're gonna say the story
might as well say the whole truth um
no matter how it makes me look
it's okay
i know why he did it and thank god we
got past it and i'm i'm thankful we got
past it but
i i pulled the trigger off in his ear to
because i knew who i had i had this kid
that came from where he came from the
streets that only believed one thing
one thing not words
and he test any yeah i said he tested
you yeah like cuss always talked about
test test test test
well he tested me
yeah is he really gonna do this yeah i'm
gonna do it and i wanted him to know not
for me but for him too for both of us
because i knew he was gonna wreck two
lives it was gonna wreck my life it's
gonna wreck my family's life and it was
gonna wreck his was gonna take his life
away
i understood that yeah people are gonna
say teddy why'd you do it then
because i understood where it was going
otherwise
so i'm not gonna lie to you
i understood all of it
that's why i pulled the trigger
i wanted him to understand it
i didn't want to have to do it
that's why i did it
i wanted him to understand
what was coming next if there was a next
and there was only one thing coming
he
his
just darkness
never see me
and it's done
and i don't want i i wanted to save the
two of us from that so that's why i did
it
and
how did he react after you pulled the
trigger in his ear
like a guy that believed
what i said
so anyway can you imagine this woman
this
agency
he's awarded to state right
now you gotta understand cuss was
already making because
very smart
he was already making arrangements to
adopt them
so he wouldn't have just hanging over
his head
to state but it was going to take time
it was a process this could have screwed
the whole thing up
if she ever found out that his trainer
who she saw these beautiful
pictures and images off doing a great
job
loving each other
just freaking
put a gun to his head yeah
it would have been all over what would
have happened in reality
they would have taken tyson back and
you know
and put him whatever put him somewhere
else whatever but
he wouldn't have been with cuss anymore
or with me obviously because i had to
make a choice and that choice did not
include teddy atlas it's that simple i
get where you're coming from and you're
right
why would you have to leave
well
there's
there was reasons why i had to leave
obviously so
it feels like it was maybe the right
choice for you though given everything
that you'd achieved and what you've done
at that point and i guess like you say
your apprenticeship maybe had been
served yeah but
going going on from there that must have
been tough for you knowing that you'd
give so much energy and effort of this
kid
who then goes on to become the youngest
heavyweight champion of the world ever
in achieving all these things
and
maybe
you know you deserve the credit for that
back in the day and you weren't getting
it
you know i spent seven maybe close eight
years but let's say seven to be solid
seven years would cost up there seven
years it's a long time
and um
yeah look it was it was what it was
there was no other there's no other real
choice at that point
so i left
yeah you know what i'm a stubborn son of
a gun i didn't leave
right away
it was a dangerous situation tyson could
come back i have to do something
whatever yeah you don't need me to paint
the picture but i stayed because stayed
away shows you how serious it got cuz
stayed away
which you know he he stayed away
sometimes but not now he shouldn't have
but he stayed away
he got reports
and i stayed for an extra week you know
why i had seven kids that was still in a
tournament up there
and they're golden gloves
and they had fought every week you know
to get to the finals and they win the
finals they deserve me to finish this
with them
not for me to abandon them i say it
again not for me to abandon them i say
it again loyalty loyalty is a great word
it sounds great but it's hard sometimes
to be loyal
i was tested i didn't want to be there
another freaking second
with what could come in that door
everything else
but
i had an obligation to these kids
young kids to win the globe finals
to see them through and i did five of
them won the gloves
and then i left
and you know what the amazing thing
about this whole thing is brian
these kids
quietly they knew what was going on
they're in a small town the school
in the gym
with you know tyson who's one of them
they knew what was going on
the last day in the gym
after they won the gloves
i you know i made them all come in so i
could just say goodbye to them
they handed me a plaque
like where'd you get this plaque from
they knew all along what was going on
they handed me a plaque it was really
nice
said um
[Music]
to teddy
atlas
who's been our father
our guide our mentor
thank you
for helping us become men
and
it was funny because
i didn't realize that so much time had
gone by
it takes different things sometimes to
mark time you know
kind of like when you have a kid you and
you put them against the wall and you
mark where his head is with the pencil
and then some time later you put him
there and you see that
you know you seen his groaning you
didn't notice it because he was next to
you you know
and then you see it on a wall
i was i walked home that night
i was living with my wife
or we were about to have our first child
and um so we were living in an apartment
because i used to live at the house for
all those years with
lacrosse and camille and a couple
fighters tyson was one of them
so i i decided to walk home it was a bit
of a walk but it was
the right thing to do
i felt i wanted a walk
and
these were little kids these were 12
year old 11 year old kids
when you know when they came into my
life
and they wrote those words which was you
know men
and all of a sudden i'm walking all of a
sudden a pickup truck pulls up
and i look teddy you need a ride
and it's all these kids
and i said to myself jesus
they're driving
they've grown up
anyway that was
that was the end of that part and then i
you know
took care of my family took care of what
i had to do
and then
went
moved
packed up the truck and moved to new
york city
and uh training fighters
finishing uh finishing what had to be
finished i guess
well i think it's lovely that you
received that from those kids i mean it
shows the impact that you had on them
because a lot of people want to hear the
mike tyson story but it's not just him
it's so many other people's lives that
you've touched clearly and when when
they say making us men
it i think boxing's just so much bigger
than
getting in the ring and throwing punches
isn't it it's it's and i know when you
describe it you always compare it to
life and and it's it's such a great
metaphor for life and what it teaches
you about how to
so many different things about life from
being in a boxing ring which i don't
think any other sport
gives you
and it was nice to see recently that
mike uh approached you and apologized
um and that you accepted how did that
make you feel in terms of potentially
having closure over
some painful wounds from years ago
got to go back to something said i hate
to do it but
it's all about the test if it's true
right
yeah i don't know i don't know how to
feel except
i don't know how to feel like again i'd
like to be that hero
that better person and people say wow
teddy that's so gracious and so kind of
you and so heartwarming thank you teddy
but then
if it's not all the way you felt then
you're not presenting the truth
and um
i was
i appreciated it but
i didn't know how real was i i just
didn't know
i didn't have the capacity to know maybe
i'm not smart enough
i i just didn't know because the cameras
were rolling
i was doing an espn show up in
upstate new york in the
turning stone casino indian casino up
there where
i was doing the friday night fights
obviously the commentator for that
and it was
the funny thing was the mike tyson for
uh production because he had become a
a promoter for a few minutes you know
it didn't last that long a year or so
i'm doing my job i know he's in a
building somewhere but i'm not paying
attention
i'm paying attention
to being a professional doing what i
have to do
and then all of a sudden my uh
producer
my beloved producer
says hey teddy i don't want to throw off
your concentration um but uh mike
tyson's walking towards you
[Laughter]
thanks ravi for not throwing off my
concentration i love you too
you know was that the first time you'd
like been in the same room since the
confrontation no
no it wasn't
it wasn't but it was the first time that
we were
we were gonna have
conversation as it turned out or
you know have any kind of uh
actually coming to the point
of talking and
[Music]
what happened so
so he tells me he's coming he says teddy
i just got word i don't want to try and
i'm like trying to be a pro and i got
somebody that last time
well one of the last times we were
together at least was
not the best circumstances i think you
could say right yeah and so
i i
i'm still me he's still you know what i
mean you still gotta you still are who
you are as far as the way you look at
things
and even though we were many years past
that you would hope right
and many many many things past that
right and
life past that
i still have to think what does this
mean
i don't know my producer don't know
just knows he's coming towards me right
now he hasn't gotten
more information yet
and um
[Music]
so
i just uh
i hit the mute button because you're
allowed you could do that
and i turned to a guy i trust who was
always with me
sitting behind me my man who i used to
do uh the fight plan with you remember
the fight plan we would illustrate what
was going to happen and he's a former
fighter and he's my he's like my brother
i just said
let me know what shoulder he's
approaching
so i just want to know what side i got
to be aware
is it this side
or this side and let me just let me know
when he's close
so i'm ready
just in case god forbid he wasn't coming
with beautiful
thoughts
which he was
again hold up it's hard to break because
told me you gotta test me
gotta test them gotta test them
so i'm aware you know a little bit now
and then um
[Music]
then he apparently stops behind me
a bit of a distance
that apparently he did
and robbie says to me he wants
permission to
say sorry he wants to be able to say
sorry i don't mean to make that sound
like i'm
giving him i i'm sorry if it sounded
that way i i i didn't mean but he wants
to make sure it's okay he's being
gracious he's being a gentleman he's
being what you would want someone to be
okay
maybe he's being better than me
i don't know because i wasn't in that
situation i don't know if he's genuine
but i know that you got to give somebody
a chance to find out if they're genuine
and it's that's how i felt
and and i wasn't sure but
what i was sure of is if a man's gonna
come it can't be the easiest thing for
him either if he's gonna come if
right or wrong well it's still not the
easiest thing
and if he's gonna come and he's doing it
there's two ways to look at it where's
the sincerity if it's on tv why isn't it
privately but there's another side that
i think i'm smart enough to understand i
hope
in some ways that's even harder that's
even harder and i i grabbed on to that
thankfully somebody upstairs
must have helped this stubborn son of a
gun understand that
where
because i probably wasn't smart enough
myself but i did understand it for him
to do that in front of people that's
even harder
like god so if he's going to put his
hand out and ask me to shake it
who the fake am i to say no
and
so i turned around
and there he was he came he walked up
you know
and he's
the best i can remember
you know it's been some years but he
said um
i'm sorry
and then he said the best thing i think
in the world
and again you don't know do you know hey
you don't know but it was nice to hear
it
he said i love you
oh
and almost nice
we shook hands and we gave each other a
hug and um it was nice i mean it was
nice
it was nice i hope he's people ask me
you know they said teddy
i said listen i just hope he's okay
i hope he's at peace i hope he's in a
good place
he was very honest about his feelings
at certain times
you know i knew things most people
didn't know but at certain times you
know he was very honest
where he didn't really like himself
and he didn't trust people around them
and he didn't feel they were around them
it's a tough thing on a person to feel
that people are only around you because
of what you can give them not what they
can give you
which is just loyalty friendship support
love
and and he was very he was smart he was
always had a
innate intelligence about him and you
know he he said it one time remember i
heard him say one time
and uh i remember my wife who's smarter
than i am she said what how does that
make you feel to hear that because i i
didn't try to hear too much of things
that he would do over the years i'm not
saying i ran from it but i i didn't look
to hear it
and it was one sometimes it just happens
and you hear it and he was basically
talking about
he don't have no friends he don't have
nobody and these people were kind of
embarrassed because they were all at a
press conference around him and he was
basically he was basically saying i
don't have no one i can trust i don't
have no friends i got basically nothing
but you know whatever that means leeches
right and and um
i didn't and she said how does that make
you feel hearing that and i said it
makes me feel a little bit of two things
and and i'm again i don't care how it
sounds i care about it's how i felt you
tell the truth or you keep your mouth
shut yeah you don't try to satisfy
people you satisfy yourself and i said
to her
this might sound small on my part honey
but
it makes
it makes me feel good to get those
people to have those people have to hear
that
to throw that right at them to hear the
truth
about what they are
and and how little
they are as people
and how unrespected they are as people
what they
what
what their actions have sold
what they really heard today makes me
feel kind of good
uh
and it makes me feel a little sad
for him and it's hard for me to feel sad
for a guy that you know what happened
happened with us but
it made me feel sad for him
because i never meant for him to you got
to remember the genesis of our
relationship
was to become better to become stronger
to become great
to become happy
yeah to become successful
that was the goal
that so
anyway that was his story teddy you're
an amazing speaker honestly you are a
truly amazing speaker um
so when i uh when i initially uh
set this interview up i had kind of
planned to do
a lot of the life story of teddy but
there is just so much to cover so i'm
thinking
we'll kind of
put that bit on pause and hopefully do a
part two at some point to get
the rise of your career and all of the
coaching and all the world champions and
um
if you don't mind we could do that down
the road sometime
and and for now i'd like to get your uh
take on some of the uh
a few of the current events um
anthony joshua has basically
admitted on a recent interview that he
would
potentially consider stepping aside
at taking a payment and allowing usyk
and fury to fight
i wondered what you made of that and
what that tells you about where anthony
joshua is and i mean the old saying you
know action is better than words
you can tell a lot about a person by
their action
and their decisions
not so much always about their words
words can be
you know deceiving well it's interesting
you would say that teddy because at the
start of the interview he kind of says
i wouldn't uh not people know better
than to offer me a step aside my people
but then by the end of the video
he said he's kind of saying yeah maybe i
would actually so
um i don't know what i don't know if he
even knows what he wants to do but um
he definitely did he didn't seem very
confident i mean he knows what appeals
to him the most yeah that's for sure
um
if i had to be a forecast of
people's human nature and i do have to
be that in this business
you gotta know more than x's and o's
you gotta know
what a person feels
what they're inclined to do for the
reasons they're inclined to do it you
got to know the human nature you gotta
you gotta understand human nature you
know because just to say to me okay
you're gonna teach somebody to slip a
punch it's not a
usually athletically uh
re
required
a movement where you have to have great
abilities you you slip from the waist up
a lot of people don't teach it right but
it should be one piece your head it
should be like a metal rod goes down
from your head to your waist and all one
piece moves because some people move
this way they leave the head on the side
and you get clipped and they don't know
why so you got to move the whole thing
one piece the whole thing and you and
what you got to understand
it's not about what you're doing it's
what you're not doing you don't pull
back you don't turn if you turn your
head's still in the path of the punch
you pull back you're still in the path
to the punch
so
you have to
control those things
he said it doesn't take athleticism
to make that move
it takes discipline it takes emotional
control
it takes that kind of inner strength
it takes
wanting to do it more than not wanting
to do it it takes if you will if you
want to go that far
a lot of things
it takes a complete
commitment of your character
to just to get to the point where you
can you know look at something dangerous
face something dangerous
and not let it make you do what you feel
like doing you feel like pulling away
you feel like turning
you don't feel like staying right in the
pocket waiting for it
and doing that you have to understand
that as a trainer so you have to
understand when it when
a man named joshua
says that
that's what he feels like doing
more than
the other things
that are required
to maybe be great it doesn't make him a
bad guy
doesn't make him a bad fighter what it
makes them is
a guy
who is limited to how great he can be
what it makes him is a guy
they can't be what all maybe other
people want him to be we can't you can't
make someone be what you want them to i
used to believe
to a certain degree
with the will of strength of mind that i
could put that into someone else
whenever in a dire situation in a dire
situation is when you get in the ring
that's that's a pretty tough situation
facing what you have to face
the threat
the unknown the imagination
the danger
it's a difficult place to be put
and i used to think that
i would i got this from cost that i i
would just force my will
into them
but you can't they are what they are and
you can make them better by making them
aware of things
and giving them
the tools the wherewithal
they need
to deal with those things to the best of
their ability but they still have to
want to deal with them because just to
say people born around don't die square
he he said teddy you
you're going to try to change their
nature
but at the end of the day you're dealing
with their nature so you got to give
them surrounding things
to make their nature
as fortified as possible
for the things they're going to deal
with
but you're still dealing with their
nature
you know you don't always need a
polygraph test
to
to tell the truth
the truth comes at you in in ways of
action
you know
i i used to say when i was calling the
fights on espn
right now
if there was a polygraph test going on
he this fighter would be telling you
that he doesn't want to fight anymore
he didn't need him to verbalize it
his actions verbalized it
well the same thing from
to you brian to the to that question
i think his action verbalizes
how he feels
what's most important to him where his
confidence is and stops where it begins
where it ends
what's most important one of the things
i said on my podcast when i was breaking
down his fight with uh music with you
sick in his last fight
and now this might sound mean but i
swear it's not mean it's not meant to be
mean it's meant to be
something that a person in the
businesses i've been almost 50 years
is aware of that's all and i have to be
aware of it because i have a
responsibility
to my fighters
to be aware of it to turn every stone
over to give them the best chance to win
and every truth to fight off
the things that are untruths
and the fighters don't always like that
but
they need it
so when i watched that fight the most
telling thing to me was
at the end
because right after that correct me if
i'm wrong i get my chronology messed up
sometimes but though the wilder fight
came after that right the wilder and so
so uh fury fight right yeah yeah so it
was um it was just uh aj first and then
wilder fury three after yeah that's what
i thought yeah so after the water fight
which i picked him to win which my
beautiful brothers and sisters over in
the uk will remind me if i forget that
you know i don't need a chronology for
that
they they love me they're gonna remind
me oh yeah teddy you you definitely
picked uh water and um one of the things
that people knocked water for was the
way he behaved afterwards or saw loser
let's say they did
and it wasn't appreciated
and people were
you know they were they were on them for
that and right i get it i get it
rightfully so here's what i said and i
think this in a nutshell
encapsulates what i'm what i'm talking
about here after the fight with uzik
i kind of wish
if i was his trainer maybe if i was
involved in his future
that joshua will be a little less of a
good loser
like it
that he would behave like it mattered
more
the greatest fight is
and the greatest successes in this world
one of the trademarks of them for me
as they go about their next business
as if
no matter how much success they've had
prior
they go about their next
situation of whatever it is that brings
them success
as if their bank account is still at
zero
joshua behaved after that fight like his
bank account is pretty far past zero
pretty damn good
and i listen again he's a gentleman he's
a nice guy
he's
he's all of that
and he's made you people proud
but that was my answer
that i wish that he had a little bit of
that sore loser like water does
in him
after a fight that's supposed to be so
meaningful so when i tell you it's so
you would say that because in this
interview
he literally stipulates his three things
that he values the most and he says i
want my respect i want to be thought of
as a throwback fighter who for anyone
and last of all i want to be known as a
good businessman
and that good businessman thing
like it's only one thing out of the me
and three things and yet the more he
talked about it the more he leaned
towards
oh well maybe i would take the money
maybe i would you know what i mean and
it
it just didn't fill me with that eye of
the tiger confidence that you're looking
for from an englishman i want him to win
these fights but it was just
it's not a good look is it when
someone's talking about taking a payout
instead of taking a rematch in a fight
that he was schooled in in the in the
original fight you know
no but what it is is the truth
you're not happy about it yep because
it's not the truth you wanted to hear
that you hoped you would hear
but but you got to give him credit for
telling the truth
it's the truth
michael jordan was a hell of a
businessman he owns half a nike
but he would cut your freaking throat
out
your heart out on the floor on that
beautiful parquet floor
in a second
to get another win no even though he
owned there for nike yeah it didn't
matter
that's why michael jordan is
michael jordan and then there's other
guys that are
as talented and this sounds like a far
reach but it's true
as talented as michael jordan but
there'll never be michael jordan
because it didn't matter winning didn't
matter that much and listen sometimes
maybe we get things out of perspective
maybe we get things screwed up
maybe we're wrong brian you know you got
to be a family man you got to be this
you got to be a businessman you got to
all those things but we're not talking
about that are we no we're not
no we're not
we're talking about what we want our
guys to be
we want our guys to be
everything
that they're capable being we want to
believe that's what they want
that they that they that they wanted as
much as we wanted that that we wanted
them to say
no i got enough freaking money and even
if i didn't have enough money there's
something more important than money i
want that freaking title back that's
what we want them to be we want them to
be that that that's how we stack up our
heroes that's how we stack up our you
know the
the people we maybe don't idolize that's
too strong a word but that we connect
with that that we
want to represe want representing us
yeah yeah that's that's what we want you
guys play soccer you have a big sock
it's the world game it's it's the
universal game and you got great soccer
teams over there you you want your
soccer player when when he gets kicked
in the [__] and there's blood coming
down and his freaking knee is twisted
you when there's mud on his face you
want him to freaking get up and freaking
take that ball and take it down the
field and put it in the freaking net
that's what you want you don't want him
saying i i i can't play no more
i i i need a penalty kick no you just
want him
to want what you want victory
you want them yeah
teddy it's
i want him to behave like a fighter
and
and it really
it it lands with me because because
that's the thing with aj in that first
fight
when the fight was getting away from him
he seemed content to just allow that to
happen
and and instead of risking it all to get
it back and that's the problem i've got
right now with him listen
like him or not like him i don't like
the personality of louder i believe in
telling the truth i think that's
becoming clear even when it's to my uh
less than my betterment um
but and it's what got me pushed away
from uh espn and corner fights because i
told the truth about a fight in
australia against a guy named jeff horn
and pacquiao when i thought that uh that
juan didn't win uh okay and and you pay
the price for those things and i'm
willing to pay that price no problem
it's okay i'm not in love with it
sometimes but it's it's
it's part of uh
it's part of the deal so
you know you can't have both sometimes
you can't have your cake you need it too
so i i don't love wilder's personality
but i tell you what i do love about him
he didn't take the step aside money he
said i want the freaking chance at the
title i want this guy
i want this guy who just freaking didn't
beat him he knocked him out i'll say it
again he didn't beat him he knocked him
out i want this no but you could get a
few million dollars or how many of the
millions dollars and and you and you
still could i want it now
i gotta admire that that'd be the way he
fought he fought like a fighter should
fight you gave everything and left it
all in there he fought like i said on my
podcast that's why i gave him a chance
he fought like a guy who was fighting
for his identity
he was fighting for who he is and who he
can be and who's he allowed to be and
who can he can feel like and who he
would see you know it's an old
sometimes
overused cliche you who do you see when
you look in the
mirror know
unfortunately today i don't think people
see anything they don't give a crap uh
they just see a beard or they don't see
a beard and then they leave and if they
see a beard they put shaving cream on it
i
unfortunately i don't think they figured
see what they should see but
that's what wilder was really sometimes
those cliches come true
that's what wilder was fighting for
brian that night to see who the fig was
going to look back at him in the mirror
to see if he ever was a champion he
fought a lot of setups let's be honest
they all do but he fought a lot of
setups
and
he did and then he finally he finally
fought
a fighter a complete fighter and he had
a draw
some people didn't think he deserved it
whatever he had a draw and then he got
knocked out
so was he ever the champion i'm being
very serious right now was he ever a
champion
he he looks in that for himself he's got
to feel like was i ever a champion i'd
be when i had to fight all you bleed the
only real fight i ever had to fight okay
you could save fort ortiz ortiz was 40
years old all right i'll give you that
okay but
the time he had to fight a guy in his
prime a good solid freaking fighter
an undefeated fighter a guy who called
wanted to be called what you're called a
champion a guy who earned or wanted to
earn the right to be called a champion
behave like a guy who wanted to earn the
right to be called a champion the first
time you fight him or the second time
the first time you get a draw a second
time you get knocked out
he's not stupid he has to live with
himself before he's got to live with me
or you or anybody else's thoughts or
even with his bank account he's got to
walk down that street
look in that mirror
[Music]
and feel
like he who he earned to feel like did
he earn the right to feel like a
champion that you could arguably say
that the first time he was asked to
fight like a champion and with the
champion and behave like a champion he
lost
does he have to was he ever a champion
did he have the right to walk down and
and say yeah yeah that's me i'm the
champ or that's the guy who knocked out
30 freaking guys that were doormen
somewhere
and and now he fights to the real
champion and he gets knocked out no he
was fighting for his identity that's
more powerful than anything he was
fighting for the right to feel the way
he wanted to feel the rest of his
freaking life on this planet
he was real-life movie sometimes movie
stuff becomes reflective of real life
he was rocky he was rocky in the movie i
know it's fictional my beautiful
brothers and sisters over there in the
uk but he was
he was rocky when he was gonna fight
clubba lang and mickey's trainer said i
don't want that fight you're not
fighting them it knocked you into
tomorrow
what are you talking about i'm a
champion mickey i beat all these guys
they were setups they weren't real guys
they were sit-ups you know
this guy knocked your head off he goes
what are you saying mickey what are you
saying there were fixed fights no but
they were hand-picked they weren't
champions
so what so i was never a champion i was
never a champion
i was never a champion
so now rocky had to freaking fight him
after getting his block knocked off
he had to fight him what was he fighting
for he wasn't fighting for a purse
anymore i guarantee you that he had
enough money he wasn't fighting for a
freaking title he already had that
that's paper or whatever they make it up
with these these titles these belts you
want a belt i'll get your belt no
problem so he wasn't fine i'll get you
one i'll get you a couple
he wasn't fighting for that
he was fighting for himself
he was fighting for redemption
he was fighting to stay out of hell yeah
regret is hell
is a solo
prison
that has bars believe me not the truth
he was fighting to freaking know who he
was
who he ever was
who he ever was and he was fighting for
one last thing
to be
what he wanted to be the rest of his
life to feel the way he needed to feel
like a champion the rest of his life
that's what got him off the floor that's
what got him this freaking close to
winning that fight by knockout when he
dropped fury twice
that's what allowed him to go
where his body didn't want to go anymore
where his body almost couldn't go in he
dragged his body to those late rounds
dragged it
dragged it you know why
because of every word i just said
that's why the only difference was he
was in there with the same kind of guy
he was in there with the same kind of
guy the guy that looked at the devil and
told him to get lost
the guy who looked at the devil in the
eyes
making him think about taking his own
life which no man should ever think
about
and he told the devil get out of here
get the f out of here
he was fighting that guy
and
the guy who knew how to fight better
there's no disputing that because you
should say to me teddy it's a
prerequisite people say oh he's tough
he's there and our business you better
be tough otherwise you better get
another vocation you better get another
living go out on the street corner and
freaking sell italian isis somewhere all
right
really go ahead
you better be tough because would always
say to me you got two tough guys
and then one becomes smarter he's
smarter he's better taught he's got
better technique he's more together he's
more of the package
boom
that guy becomes twice as tough he
becomes tougher it's true
that's what we had that night
but everything i just described that
behavior everything that i just put out
there joshua
i'm not knocking him
he's not driven by that
i'm not saying everyone is
it's obvious that's what separates
people and makes people special but i'm
not saying he's not a good fighter but i
am saying
he's not that
and um he had you know he he had his
choice and his choices to do what he
said be a businessman be smart take the
money and okay
that's fine but guess what
that shows up in the ring
it shows up
it it doesn't get left you don't say all
right i'm busy now i'm putting this hat
on i had my business hat now i put my
fighter's hat i'll take it a step closer
or farther brian i'll put my
championship
special hat on right now no no no no it
don't work that way
it's connected
and it shows
and it showed already and it has shown
already that's why i tell you
you didn't
you know i heard he's coming to the
states and all that i don't know if he
made his decision yet to get another
trainer i don't know if that's because i
don't follow it as close as you might
think uh somebody that's in the business
but you know i heard like everyone else
that he was he went over to you know see
canelo's training went to see this guy
went to see that guy um you know went to
see a new taylor um you know whatever um
in this
in the states we've got good tailors
over here too but
you know but
i mean
obviously right away people said teddy
did he come to see you or did he talk to
you
no
and nor should he why
i'm not that important but i'll tell you
one thing the funny part was somebody
said if he did
we shouldn't talk and if no no but teddy
if he did if he did
um and here you're gonna you're gonna
well maybe you're
not that you don't understand where i'm
at already but this
kind of drives it home and this was
somebody very close to me
asking me the question i say who it was
it was my son my son is the director of
scouting for the
vegas raiders my daughter i got two
children i'm very blessed she's a lawyer
he he does that and it's not because of
what they are professionally it's what
they are as people i am so proud of them
i i'm proud he's a very smart she's very
smart he's a very smart kid and he's the
only one who would ask a question like
this he said dad
dad
i i know he's not coming i get it he's
never going to ask you as a whatever and
you're retired now anyway but i just
for me because i already think i know
the answer
and i think it's the opposite of what
people would think they're going to hear
but if you had your choice if between
training him if he did ask you
and training water
who would you
very interested who would you take that
and without hesitation
and he just smiled
because
i said
wow
i can't stand the guy we don't like each
other
i don't like i don't like his
personality i don't like the way he
conducts himself the way he talks
sometimes
but it's no contest
i like the way he behaves
i like the way he behaves in that
freaking ring i like the way that he
puts it all on the line i like the way
he shows you where his cards are to the
point
where what he wants
what's important to him i can work with
that
the other guy
it would be much easier
he's uh he's a nice guy prob maybe a
nicer guy i don't know but but a guy you
could get along with and everything else
but
he's not the guy that i want to be in a
foxhole with it it's funny that
this kind of comes back the way you were
sort of describing your issues with mike
tyson is a lot of people spoke about
anthony joshua in the exact same way
he's the natural he's got it all the
speed the agility the power
the the reach the size everything but
when he's been tested
by andy ruiz now obviously you sick did
he pass those tests and obviously he
came back against ruiz and fought him in
a completely different way and and all
of that
but a lot of people weren't happy with
how he behaved in the corner when he was
getting beat up when he didn't show the
willingness that tyson fury showed
um and i guess now
for that reason that is why you would
pick wilder because of that lack of
that certain aspect of a fighter one one
other question before i go
uh i love the fact that you're making
mma videos and and and your your take on
mma is is great because you've got so
much fighting knowledge from boxing and
bringing it into the sport and dustin
poirier is is um a very good friend of
yours and he recently gave an interview
where he said
that you sent him a bit of tape on conor
mcgregor
um before the win
uh where you pointed out some things t
that uh
and
when you looked at how good porrio's
boxing looked at times and how he was
catching mcgregor with the check hook
i just wondered what it was you've seen
and uh
what you said in the video
all right again we've been
right we're talking about you
gotta always be accurate right i mean
you you sometimes you don't have to be i
didn't say you said it so i could just
leave it um as being that it sounds
better it sounds stronger so i could
just leave it like that but
it wouldn't be exactly accurate i gave
him a fight plan but not a video i
talked about knowing what the guy is
you got to know what the guy is
what he is and what he is the guy's a
great counter puncher don't give him
counter punching opportunities it's not
that complicated
um
[Music]
don't reach
um use faints
get him to
show his hand before
you show yours
uh fade him he wants to kinda
uh get him off balance with her fate
don't come in the front door counter
punches need you to come in the front
door come in the side door most
important understand range
look some people don't talk about what
connor he's a tremendous kind of puncher
great counterpuncher he's a pioneer in
the sport he's like ali in some ways
people get crazy when i say it because
his behavior hasn't always been good
outside whatever but i gotta give him
credit with his credit still you know
give the devil's due
when muhammad ali brought the purses to
uh
to a level that the promoters never paid
mcgregor
has
brought those purses to a place
that never worked before mcgregor
and some fighters some people say not
enough but listen there's a lot of ufc
fighters benefiting from from that
because of him
uh as a pioneer in that way he's a great
counter puncher and he's a tremendous
puncher with his left hand the power
punch for some southpaws where you could
turn into it with your back leg
and you could get your
your body into it um but there's another
aspect and i made him very aware of this
his left hand is very long he's got a
long reach that's what helped him be
ahead and i'll say it again people get
crazy
i was at the fight covering him for espn
when he fought mayweather he was ahead
and he'd be in mcgregor after four
rounds like it or not yes he was he was
smart he was controlled and he was using
his reach to the southpaw reach to keep
a counter puncher from counter-punching
and he did it very well the first four
rounds
until mayweather started to walk him
down
and get him into waters that were in his
waters he's got a long reach it's hard
to judge that
until you're in the ring
and by then it's too late
where
that left hand goes maybe four inches
longer than someone else's left hand
would go so where you're out of range
with somebody else you're still in range
with conor mcgregor like i said don't
feed into the strengths
of what are his strengths
which is counterpunching which means
making mistakes reaching in being you
know being at the wrong distance and
bring him to the places where he's not
in his
wheelhouse
where he's not in his comfort zone so
that was there was other things but that
was that was the
that was the crux of it that was the
basis of it and listen i was so happy he
won well teddy um i'm i'm gonna wrap it
there but um i just want to say i think
the world are you mate i think you're a
great guy i think what you've done for
boxing is amazing i can't wait to talk
to you again about the rest of your
career i love your channel love your
podcast i'm a massive fan and i really
appreciate the time
you your passion
for
boxing nobody comes close to it you are
the most passionate guy about the sport
and uh the way you talk no one can
compare so thanks for what you give us
all as fans of the show and i look
forward to watching you more and more
mate thank you brian you're a gentleman
uh you represent your people over there
very well
and
give them my love i will do me i'll tell
them all teddy says hi and not to hate
on you if you ever pick against tyson
fury again
[Laughter]
i don't think i ever pick against that
guy again it's gonna be different i
don't know but but but if there's one
guy i would pick against him with it
well there's already been a couple so i
should i gotta i gotta fix that um but
if there was another guy if i would go
down that road a little further it might
be with music because that man knows how
to win absolutely it could happen i mean
that fight looks like it's going to
happen now with eddie hearn
saying they're in talks to step aside
now it could happen so if the money's
right we might see that next so i'll
keep in touch and i'll i'll definitely
uh do this again sometime if everyone
wants to check out teddy's podcast the
link will be in the description below
they do amazing fight videos great
interviews i'm a huge fan and thanks
very much teddy appreciate you
thank you brian appreciate you